welcome to the future of life institute
podcast i'm lucas perry today's episode
is with fy team members anthony aguirre
and anna yelazarova and is meant to
provide information about the fy world
building contest in short this is a
contest which invites teams from across
the globe to compete for a prize purse
of up to a hundred thousand dollars by
designing visions of a plausible and
aspirational future that includes strong
artificial intelligence if you want to
know more about this competition and how
to get involved you can listen to this
podcast or head over to
worldbuild.ai for more information
before we jump into the interview and in
case you didn't catch it in the david
chalmers episode i'll be moving on from
my role as host of the fy podcast and
this means two things the first is that
fli is hiring for a new host for the
podcast as host you would be responsible
for the guest election interviews
production and publication of the fy
podcast if you're interested in applying
for this position you can head over to
the careers tab at futureoflife.org for
more information
we also have another four job openings
currently for a human resources manager
an editorial manager an eu policy
analyst and an operations specialist you
can learn more about those at the
careers tab as well
the second item is that even though i'll
no longer be the host of the fli podcast
i won't be disappearing from the
podcasting space i'm starting a brand
new podcast focused on exploring
questions around wisdom
philosophy science and technology where
you'll see some of the same themes we
explore here like existential risk and
ai alignment i'll have more details
about my new podcast soon if you'd like
to stay up to date you can follow me on
twitter at lucasfm perry link in the
description
and with that i'm happy to introduce
anthony aguirre and anna yela zarova on
fy's new world building contest
so welcome to the podcast anna and
anthony it's great to have you
uh today we're here to talk about fly's
new world building contest which is
quite a new exciting initiative that you
guys have both put a ton of time into
working on so i have a two-part question
to start things off here the first is
what is world building and the second is
what is effeli's world building contest
well when i start out with uh world
building itself
so world building is the process of kind
of constructing a
fictitious world in which a story or a
a movie or a novel or something takes
place so
if you think about for example star wars
there's the star wars movies and then
there's the star wars world that they
inhabit um it has certain rules like
there are
uh there's the force you know there are
spaceships faster than light travel is
pretty easy um ais aren't really really
hard because there's only like human
level robots
um
there
are you know there there are different
politics that are happening in the
galaxy there's a certain level of you
know span of technologies
and so so they're all these kind of
rules to the world and then within that
set of rules they're all there there are
a lot of different
artifacts so there's tatooine you know
the desert planet and it's got its own
whole feel and it's politics and
sociology and things and then there are
other planets and then there's the
the shape of the star destroyer so there
are all these things that have been
constructed creatively to inhabit that
world uh that is governed by some set of
rules so world building is the is the
process of constructing that
fictitious reality including all the
details of you know how the politics
work what is the technology
uh what is in it
what are the what sorts of people are in
it what is its history you know what has
happened in the past and so on and the
idea is to to give you a backdrop for
really imagining that you're in this
world so a a really good worldview is
kind of this evocative thing where you
feel like ah i could i could be in that
it's it's something that i can sort of
experience in my mind and that gives you
the feeling of reality because it has
been thought through in this
self-consistent way you kind of
understand what the rules are um and you
you know you know you'd be surprised if
certain things happen in star wars that
are coming from star trek or vice versa
those are different worlds
that have different sets of rules in
them
so so this is a process that's been
developed
both kind of informally you know anybody
who's writing say a science fiction
novel or a fantasy novel or something
has some world building element to it
because there's this you know an
imagined world in which the story is
taking place
but it's also been sort of developed
more professionally so there's a whole
industry say in in hollywood of
constructing the world that you know the
marvel universe or the star wars or that
star trek inhabits so there are people
who are actually doing this for a living
building fictitious worlds and inventing
the artifacts that are in those worlds
and there are world building programs
you know university programs that you
can learn how to do this process so it's
it's a minor industry but an important
one because it it's in a lot of our
media
the idea of this contest is to sort of
retask this
way of thinking about things of
constructing fictitious worlds to try to
construct some
plausible and aspirational versions of
our own actual world
so
not necessarily to you know for some
other purpose to to put a story into but
to investigate those worlds
uh on their own and to enjoy the process
of making them and think about what goes
into making that world and then kind of
explore the variety of different worlds
that people come up with so
the idea of the fli world building
contest
is to
sort of create a competition where the
goal is to
as teams
invent
the a sort of fictitious world that
exists in 2045
it's a world that should make sense be
internally consistent you know follow
the laws of physics have plausible
technology for 2045 and we'll we'll get
to some of those ground rules um but it
but very importantly it's it's also
supposed to be aspirational so it's
supposed to be a world that we would
like to inhabit we'll talk a little bit
about you know why we chose to do it
that way instead of just any old world
in any old time and so on but the idea
is to to
gather up lots of interesting
contributions from teams around the
world and incentivize them with this
contest with a nice juicy prize purse
to get people really working hard and
putting effort into this world build
why is it important to do world building
for 2045 i think the year 2045 is
interesting because it's still in the
somewhat near future where most of us
would still be alive so it's very easy
to imagine as opposed to a very distant
world you know where you can reimagine
um almost everything here we're trying
to keep a lot of uh what we know what
exists today
but then
with a set of constraints
help us do this thought experiment about
how we managed to overcome certain
challenges that we already see on the
horizon
so the idea of world building for 2045
is just a constraint
to uh focus this exercise but we might
you know we might do
a different world build that's in a more
distant future but for now this is to um
yeah to focus ourselves
given humanity's track record of
ramrodding our way into new technologies
and worlds just following kind of like
natural economic incentives why is it
important that
we have a world building contest that we
we practice world building
so i think as
both as individuals and as a society
we're
we're fairly goal directed you know in
in general we we have goals for our
personal life on a day-to-day basis and
on a on a longer time scale we have
goals you know for to have a good career
to be happy in this way and that to have
a good relationship for maybe to have
kids maybe for them to have good things
happen to them so we have these
long-term goals and we work toward them
if we
uh if we didn't have those goals if we
just every day sort of
um
woke up and sort of went through some
random set of motions that would be an
okay way to live but we
we would have a very different life than
uh if we had some choices about what
were more and less desirable for our
life and aim toward them
and i think as a
as a society
we can do much the same thing we can
have some level of goals as a
as a society
and work toward them
i think often we have done that less you
know lately in society than we than we
perhaps did in the past i think there's
a sense
that
you know there are there's progress but
it's mostly technological progress and
it's maybe a little bit of social
progress but it's kind of just pushing
us along and we're just going where the
where the techno social progress takes
us and there's not really much we can do
about that you know there's kind of
capitalism and there's technology and
wherever they go we just have to like
ride it out as best we can
and i think this is a very disempowered
way to look at the world you know we
as a society just like as individuals
have a lot of agency as to what happens
to us we make decisions and those
decisions have real consequence
and
part of the idea of
of this contest is to do a little bit
more thinking about what are some
possible goals you know if we think
about the world 25 years from now
if we imagine a world that we actually
want to inhabit
there
you know we're not going to end up
living in that world the the world is
too unpredictable and things are not
going to go the way that we want just
like regular life
but if you don't have any goal at all
it's very hard to know what to work
toward and what to do now in order to
get there so the idea here is to
kick start a process of
thinking through what would we like the
future to look like
not just vaguely like we haven't
destroyed the world through global
warming or through ai catastrophe or
through biotech catastrophe like that's
good that's important we really
definitely want to
not destroy the world but going a little
bit beyond that what do we actually want
it to look like and are there things
that we can do now to
start to plant the seeds for that kind
of world
and you can't plant the seeds now if you
don't really know what kind of world you
want to grow into so the goal of this is
to
sort of
plant some posts down the line line two
decades from now of
wow wouldn't it be cool if the world was
like this
here's what would have to happen between
now and then if the world was going to
be something like that
and
again
that probably will go go astray like
it's not going to end up quite the way
you want it to
but i think
just as in your individual life pushing
in like a more positive direction and
having a goal
um doesn't guarantee you're going to get
that you're going to reach it but is
probably a more positive and you're
going to get closer to that goal than if
you don't have a goal at all or if you
have some radically different goal so
the idea here is to to start that
process and
um
to
engage a lot of the creativity that has
gone into imagining
negative worlds like
so that so there's a lot of
effort that has gone into imagining
dystopias and just various ways that the
world can go off the rails
i think this is good you know i think we
as individuals we also imagine all the
things that can go wrong you know uh as
a parent you think of every possible
thing that can go wrong with your kids
they still they find more um
and that's good because that's how you
protect your kids from getting you know
run over by a car eaten by a lion or
whatever um you imagine these things and
you prevent them and as a society we
definitely have to do this too but if
all you're ever imagining for your kids
is all the terrible things that can
happen to them then you're also not
going to be a great parent because
you're not going to be thinking about
the opportunities and you're not going
to be weighing you know risks against
benefits and so on
so
we i think
it is really important to think about
all the ways that things can go wrong
and work to prevent them
but we don't want to just be living in
this
idea that the world is definitely going
to be a
catastrophe a little bit down the line
we don't want to only be focused on the
way that everything can go wrong
we want to spend some time thinking
about what we would like in sort of
concrete and evocative detail
and is there anything else that you'd
like to add here in terms of perspective
on what world building is and and why
it's important well i guess what anthony
is touching in is not only the
importance of world building but uh also
positive
world building aspirational world thing
uh world building and uh thinking more
positively about the future i think it's
a much
harder task
to imagine hopeful futures than it is to
imagine
everything that could go wrong because
for you to have a rich detailed world
build of a positive future you actually
have to have answers
to some of the most pressing challenges
of our time
and that thought exercise is very
valuable and um
and there's so many takes on it
and i think we really want to hear from
a very diverse set of people
to see both um
what people want
and also um how we can get there
and the idea is not just to keep
talking to our existing community
ecosystem but really to branch out
to as many people around the world to
people who are in different fields
and really to get to hear from them
because it's going to be hard to
have a consensus on what kind of future
we want
so part of this uh world building
contest is also being open to different
perspectives and
um yeah hearing each other out because
even agreeing on a future we want is a
huge huge challenge
um so yep the contest is definitely
aiming at a very very broad
audience you could be a scientist a
policy researcher a creative a digital
artist a writer
you could be from any discipline and
still somehow contribute original
thoughts and input
in this contest and we really don't want
to discourage anyone to apply
um
so i think it's part of a bigger
conversation
and world building helps us get there
so
in terms of world building it
seems like there needs to be a lot of
constraints
that help
people you know for example in a contest
to to create that world so i'm curious
anna if you could explain
uh some more about the actual ground
rules
of this
contest um all right so the ground rules
for the contest or the set of
constraints we chose for this thought
exercise
are as follows
first of all the year is 2045 so we're
still somewhat in the near future
we could imagine most most of us would
be conceivably alive
in 2045.
agi has existed for at least five years
so we are intentionally choosing to make
artificial intelligence a big focus um
of our worlds and of this contest
which is also a big focus area of fli
agi is artificial general intelligence
and the the thing
to note about agi is
it's basically um artificial
intelligence that has reached this
milestone of being at least as good
as a human in every task um so we're
talking very advanced uh ai in this
world
then technology is advancing very
rapidly and ai is transforming the world
sector by sector so ai is the biggest um
you know leap in technology we're seeing
in this world
but ai is affecting every single
industry every single sector so if you
have a focus in any other
domain than ai you could probably
imagine ai transforming your industry
and could choose to focus on that in the
contest
anthony would you like to take the next
set of rules yeah so so then
um
we we kind of thought of ai as the the
big transformative
uh
change from what
what we know of today of course we know
that you know lots of things are
changing the world lots of technologies
are advancing
and
geopolitically and socially things are
evolving as well
but we wanted to keep some of the focus
on on what particularly is happening
with ai and so we chose to
try to sort of maintain
something like the current world insofar
as possible in the other sectors so for
example
you know right now they're kind of major
geopolitical centers in the us and the
eu and and asia and especially china so
we kind of kept that
so so the idea is that uh in 2045
there will still be the us and the eu
and china as kind of three major centers
of power there won't be like one world
government and there won't be you know a
million different uh balkanized uh
decentralized powers or something you
can imagine both of those but just to to
ground ourselves a little bit we chose
that um other regions in the world india
africa south america are also advancing
but just aren't still quite as much on
the center of the world stage another
thing that we wanted to to sort of
be a little bit conservative in and also
a little bit positive in was to say that
there just haven't been any major wars
or other global catastrophes so we
haven't had you know
coveted 20 with a that killed half of
humanity uh and we haven't had nuclear
war say between
the us and russia or anything like that
so so we've kind of muddled along at
least geopolitically and haven't had any
catastrophes that went uh
totally awry
um
and in and
pushing a little bit further in this
sort of optimistic direction
that the world is generally looking
pretty good so part of the idea of this
contest is to look for positive visions
of the future and things that we might
want to aspire to and so part of the
ground rules is just that you know the
world isn't dystopian we're not living
in 1984 or
any other
many depicted dystopias um
you know we're in one of the very few
worlds that that people would feel like
pretty good about being in um it's a
it's a somewhat funny thing that
um
in fiction
most of the time you know dystopia kind
of comes from
trying to develop a utopia and it goes
out and it goes wrong um and we're sort
of very used to this it it's almost hard
to adjust your thinking
to create a world that is actually good
um rather than
it's so easy to think of all the
different ways that it can things can go
wrong and be bad it's fun and almost
liberating to think about a world that's
actually good kind of unironically
um
and and unapologetically like this is a
world i'd like to live in um and that's
sort of what we're asking for here it's
notable that in a lot of these things
we've we've kept the world
kind of similar to how it is now
geopolitically and technologically in
wars and stuff and the world is actually
pretty okay at the moment at least for a
lot of people you know at least it's not
we're not living in a dystopia for most
people
um
so
so that in that way it's conservative
but it's important to emphasize that the
addition of artificial general
intelligence is a huge change
um that
having the ability to
replace human labor with with machines
not just physical labor but intellectual
labor means that
most jobs can be done by machine even
into you know even what we now call you
know
thought work and intellectual work can
be done by machines
productivity will be skyrocketing uh so
many more things will be possible there
will be inventions that are coming
directly out of agi and agi human
collaborations
so many many things will be very very
different because of this introduction
and
it's in a sense it's there's a little
bit of tension between
the high power and the transformative
change that agi will bring and
the conservatism that the world is not
that that that different from the way it
is now but i think this tension is part
of the job of the the entrance to
resolve like how how did that happen how
did we keep control of of agi so not
only has it not got not gone off the
rails but it hasn't totally changed the
world into something completely
radically different than we have now
so so part of the part of the job is to
figure out how did that happen what are
the course of events what are the
institutions that were necessary for
that
technically socially and so on how did
that come about and that will be part of
the fun i think to see how that worked
out
so it'd be great if we could pivot here
into a bit more of the details behind
the actual contest just so that
listeners have a sense of the due dates
what's actually expected in terms of you
know what's being delivered and all that
so um you know so what are the details
behind the behind the contest
um yeah to understand the contest i
think uh hearing what the submission
consists of will be very helpful
so to enter the contest you have to
submit four elements
the first being a timeline the second
one being short stories so writing
pieces the third being
answers to a set of questions
and lastly a piece of
non-text media or art
so for the timeline we want
applicants to provide
for every single year from today from
2022 to 2045
um
two
events and one data point per year
what is an event an event could be
an agreement an international agreement
is formed an institution is created
um
like an actual
event
whereas a data point would be more
could be
a change in gdp a change in life
expectancy so we're talking more numbers
here
um
and so this is pretty detailed we have
um over
20 years to fill in each of them having
three points
which will help with the richness of the
world and thinking through how we've
achieved certain things
um
then the short stories the short stories
have to take place in 2045
could be anywhere in the world and it
could be different characters
but ultimately you're telling
their story
in 750 to 1000 world words what does a
day in the life look like in 2045
so you're using more of a narrative tool
here you're using storytelling to give
give some more color to your world to
make it come alive then you have a set
of prompts uh you need to answer
and uh the prompts will help uh you
world build they'll be um asking how
we've overcome a set of challenges um
some of them will be very focused on ai
some of them are going to be more
general
and um you know you could definitely use
the answers to those to both shape your
timeline or think through your story
all of the elements are meant to
interact and are meant to help you with
the other tasks and for the the fourth
element uh we we were asking for a
non-text media piece
uh and this could take uh many forms
this could be a a very visual piece a
digital art this could be a video it
could also be audio but we just don't
want something that is in written form
because so much of uh the rest of the
application already focuses on that
in terms of actual
due dates and some more details here
about uh you know when this is all
wrapping up and the amount of uh money
that is being offered in terms of uh
prizes could you guys speak a little bit
more on that so for this there's there's
a pretty
uh significant prize purse so we have a
bunch of prizes one first prize of
twenty thousand dollars two second
prizes of ten thousand dollars five
third prizes of two thousand dollars and
ten fourth prizes of a thousand dollars
each and the judges have discretion to
give up to five
extra prizes of two thousand dollars
each for whatever they like it like they
could just really love uh you know a
movie and give a two thousand dollar
prize for that even if the rest of the
the build
wasn't a winner um
but we also
this doesn't totally complete the prize
package because we really want to
encourage teams to enter in this
rather than into just individuals
individuals are fine but i think this
will be much more fun if teams get
together and work on it be more
productive
so rather than forcing teams to
uh split the prize evenly which kind of
disincentivizes things we're giving a
bigger prize if you enter in a bigger
team so we'll scale up the prize so for
example if you have a five-person team
the prize has doubled and so you don't
quite get the full prize um that you
would have gotten as an individual but
you don't get a fifth of the either you
get like two-fifths uh so so we're
really hoping and we're going to put
effort into trying to help
people form teams so that by
incentivizing with the prizes but also
just doing what we can to build a
community um and to commute like help
people connect with each other because
this is a an exercise that's really fun
to do in groups i would say
in terms of important dates and
milestones for the the contest
uh the contest opened january 1st
and uh teams have until april 15th to
put in their um
their entries uh so then the contest
will will close uh april 15th
and uh the judges will take a month to
pick 20 finalists so may 15th we'll hear
about our 20 finalists and everyone will
get to
see their world builds which will be
published online
at this point there will be a month
where
anyone in the public can
input on
can a book can vote can provide feedback
and can just voice which futures they
like
so um
we'd love some audience participation
here
and then the judges uh will take the uh
audience feedback and um use that to
rank uh the the finalists um
according to
uh first second third prize etc
um so the final winners will be known
june 15th um 2022.
and and if if people want to get any
more information about the
uh contest to you know see everything
that we've talked about here in
on the fy website is the best place to
do that so we have a um a website just
uh for the contest it's
worldbuild.ai
so quite easy to remember this has all
the rules all the deadlines the prizes
everything we've talked about is on the
website so i encourage you to
look through the faqs or anything like
that
you can also join our discord if you
have questions
we'll be monitoring the the community
the online community you can also use
the discord to meet potential team
members
and
interact with other other folks
interested in the contest
and if discord isn't your um your cup of
tea you can also send an email to
worldbuild at
futureoflife.org
and we'll also be monitoring that
channel
so those are the easiest ways to get in
touch
and join the community
awesome so as we wrap up here i'm just
curious to get your final thoughts and
feelings about this this world building
project um i guess i can start with you
anthony just
you know how do you see this as as
really fitting in with you know all of
your work overall at fli and
[Music]
how do you feel about it in terms of its
place
of uh working towards beneficial futures
and mitigating existential risk first of
all i think it's going to be a
tremendous amount of fun so so we
there's a little bit of a precedent at
fli for this we
in 2019 had a meeting called the
augmented intelligence summit and that
was
i think around 40 or so 50 people that
got together essentially to do world
building uh and the the ground rules
were actually kind of similar to the
ones in this contest um
and we we did a lot of in-person
exercises uh
you know including
you know writing and talking about
stories like the ones that we have here
um
you know role-playing so you would you
know put yourself in the role of some
person in the future in this future
world all kinds of things to really
inhabit it
and i found it
uh to be really really
just enjoyable and
insight building so
for example one of the the things that
i've been thinking a lot about lately on
the ai side is the concept of
loyalty or fiduciary duty in ais so
we have humans who
have to act sort of in the interest of
their client like a doctor or a lawyer
or a financial advisor they have a legal
duty to act in the interest of their
clients
ai systems that we have right now don't
always have that same sort of obligation
on them
um
and so
in the world that we were talking about
in the augmented intelligence summit we
came up with this idea of fiduciary ai
assistance so these are assistants that
like have to act in your interest that
are acting just for you that are like a
human assistant that is your employee
you know they're just doing they're not
secretly working for some other company
or something
and that was part of the world that we
built
and so
just out of that
uh world building exercise came this
idea that has actually led to sort of
two published papers new initiatives
that we're thinking about um i don't
think we necessarily would have thought
along those lines without that world
building contest so i think
um
it's very easy to
you know if you're starting from where
we are here and you're thinking about
what the future is going to look like to
just you know make sort of minor
perturbations or just kind of push in
one direction or another a little bit
when you're forced to jump to 2045 say
you know that things are going to be
quite different and it kind of frees you
up creatively to think about how the
world could be radically different
and i think that's really really
valuable and it's also i think
the the advantage that world building
has above just well let's think about
the future and what might exist is that
in the in that case you tend to do
things sort of abstractly like the world
might have this sort of technology in it
um
but when you think of for example the
day in a day in the life of someone you
know they get into their self-driving
car
and then you're thinking about what that
means exactly you know who's the owner
of the car what you know what happens if
they've been out drinking
uh
you know does the self-driving car spy
on them or is or is there a self-driving
car kind of private inside
when you try to actually build a
fictional and very concrete world
and go into the back story of what's
behind every little piece of it you come
up with all sorts of questions that you
hadn't really considered before the
experiential side of it leads you to
encounter
that future in a way that you wouldn't
just going through a purely intellectual
exercise i think which is
really valuable and really
enjoyable and i think something that we
will
um get a lot more out of than than
purely abstract intellectual thinking
about it
anna do you have anything else that you
would like to add here in terms of you
know how this fits into your existential
risk work and what makes you so excited
about this
well i guess we're getting to the bottom
of the wise fli running this contest and
um the goals behind it and we're really
hoping that the outputs of this contest
tie into our you know real world work at
fli and aren't just these
you know creative visions we share
as anthony said there might be some
really
nuggets of wisdom some interesting
policy propositions some new
institutions
that people
describe in these world builds
that um are real ideas that maybe are
worth pursuing in the real presence in
the real world in the present
um so there's kind of this inspiration
for
how did we overcome these problems i
think it's important to say that we're
not pushing for any particular future
and um
we're mostly crowdsourcing
you know suggestions for how did we
overcome major problems how did we
ensure there was not another pandemic or
how did we ensure that ai was kept safe
and
we want to hear the answers to that so
inspire our real um life efforts at fli
another side of it is um the we're
trying to lean in hard into the
storytelling um
aspect
at fli and i know a few of our
co-workers are really passionate about
that
because storytelling can be really
powerful in convincing people that
certain risks are are real or certain
futures are worth working towards um
and i think crowdsourcing futures people
want are part of it i know that we do
want to hear
um everyone's
input perspective on the kind of futures
we find desirable
and
another another
side to this coin is
trying to actually show people what
positive
futures might look like because it's
true we have been bombarded with
bombarded with dystopia left and right
it's in
oliver fiction in hollywood it's in
books and movies it's everywhere
um
and i do think it does something to our
world view if
that's how we all think about the future
and
if we
if we as a society had a better
relationship with the future i think
people would be motivated to work
towards it as opposed to having a doom
and gloom
approach to things so there's a strong
storytelling component and we're hoping
to use these world builds
you know put them in the hands of of
storytellers we're hoping to do more
after the contest as well to
to give life to these world builds
and um yeah help people feel more
positively about the future
not in a naive way
not in in the sense of oh everything
will be fine but in the sense of like oh
if we work hard
if we tackle these problems there's this
thing really worth working towards
so we do care about inspiring people and
we sure hope to work with a lot more
storytellers
on the um
on the other side uh after the contest
is over
uh so hopefully this initiative doesn't
end with the contest itself on on june
15th
all right awesome uh thank you very much
anthony and anna i'm i'm really excited
to see what the the you know the who the
winners are um i know that you know the
quality of their worlds will be
really interesting and amazing
i'm also excited to see all the kinds of
interesting institutions that come out
of it um
and i'm especially excited for the art
pieces um that'll be really cool
so yeah thanks so much for for coming on
and if people want to get more
information i'll include links
to the website in the description of
wherever you might be listening so yeah
thank you so much
you